♪♪
>>> IT'S "WEEKEND UPDATE" WITH
COLIN JOST AND MICHAEL CHE.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING, EVERYBODY.
>> WELCOME TO "WEEKEND UPDATE."
I'M MICHAEL CHE.
>> I'M COLIN JOST.
WELL,
THIS WEEK RUSSIA BEGAN THEIR
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
MANY ANALYSTS WERE SURPRISED
THAT PUTIN WENT THROUGH WITH IT
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS OBVIOUSLY
GOING TO BE A COLOSSAL MISTAKE.
BUT HE COULDN'T BACK DOWN AFTER
ALL THAT BUILD UP.
KIND OF LIKE HOW NBC STILL HAD
TO GO THROUGH WITH AIRING THE
WINTER OLYMPICS.
EXPERTS ON RUSSIAN POLITICS ARE
SAYING THAT ECONOMIC SANCTIONS
FROM THE WEST WILL NOT DETER
PUTIN BECAUSE HIS MONEY IS IN
NON-TRADITIONAL ASSETS THAT ARE
DIFFICULT TO TRACE.
SO ON TOP OF EVERYTHING ELSE
AWFUL ABOUT PUTIN, HE'S ALSO
INTO CRYPTO.
>> AFTER THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE, THE RUSSIA STOCK MARKET
FELL BY 30% TO NEGATIVE 90%.
THAT'S A TOUGH SUBJECT TO MAKE
JOKES ABOUT.
I MEAN, WE HAVE SEEN FOOTAGE OF
ATTACKS LIKE THIS ON OTHER
COUNTRIES, BUT NEVER THE WHITE
ONES.
I DON'T KNOW VERY MUCH ABOUT
THIS WHOLE SITUATION.
BUT I HAVE A CLOSE FRIEND WHO IS
UKRAINIAN, AND I HAVE ASKED HER
WHAT SHE THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
AND SHE SAID, "MICHAEL, YOU
DON'T PAY ME TO TALK, BABY."
I AM -- I AM VERY IMPRESSED BY
ALL THE UKRAINIAN CITIZENS
SIGNING UP TO DEFEND THEIR
COUNTRY, EVEN THE FAMOUS ONES.
IMAGINE THAT HERE.
>> ONE OF THE FIRST PLACES
RUSSIAN FORCES SEIZED WHEN
INVADING UKRAINE WAS CHERNOBYL,
THE SITE OF THE 1986 NUCLEAR
DISASTER.
SAID UKRAINIANS, "OH, NO.
DON'T TAKE THAT."
CAPTURING CHERNOBYL IS LIKE
LANDING AN AUDITION FOR
HARVEY WEINSTEIN NOW.
DONALD TRUMP PRAISED
VLADIMIR PUTIN MOVING TROOPS
INTO UKRAINE, SAYING, "THIS IS
GENIUS."
"THIS IS GENIUS" IS ALSO HOW HE
SARCASTICALLY INTRODUCES ERIC.
>>> JUDGE KETANJI BROWN JACKSON
SEEN HERE GETTING TIRED OF
Y'ALL'S FOOLISHNESS WAS
NOMINATED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
BECOME THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN ON
THE SUPREME COURT.
THE NOMINATION FULFILLING
BIDEN'S PROMISE TO CHANGE THE
SUBJECT.
>> BIDEN CHOSE JACKSON AFTER
INTERVIEWING THREE FINALISTS
THIS WEEK.
WEIRD.
"I THOUGHT INTERVIEWING BLACK
CANDIDATES WAS JUST FOR SHOW,"
SAID THE NFL.
>>> A NEW BOOK CLAIMS THAT WHILE
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT,
WHITE HOUSE STAFF FOUND WADS OF
PAPER CLOGGING THE TOILET.
SO EITHER HE TRIED TO FLUSH
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, OR HE EATS
THE WRAPPERS.
>> IN THE DAYS AFTER NEW YORK
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS ANNOUNCED THE
NEW PLAN TO STOP VIOLENCE IN THE
CITY'S TRANSIT SYSTEM, SIX
PEOPLE WERE STABBED ON THE
SUBWAY.
AND I SPEAK FOR ALL NEW YORKERS
WHEN I SAY, THAT SOUNDS PRETTY
LOW.
>> IT WAS REPORTED THAT
BUCKINGHAM PALACE STAFF HAVE
BEEN MOCKING PRINCE ANDREW WITH
A NURSERY RHYME.
SAID PRINCE ANDREW, "OH,
NURSERY."
>>> OFFICIALS POSTHUMOUSLY
STRIPPED MEDINA SPIRIT OF HIS
2021 KENTUCKY DERBY VICTOR FOR
FAILING A POST RACE DRUG TEST.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY MEDINA
SPIRIT, I HOPE IT'S HOT IN HORSE
HELL, YOU CHEATING BASTARD.
>> MEDINA SPIRIT SOUNDS LIKE A
TYLER PERRY CHARACTER.
>>> A DOG IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WENT MISSING 12 YEARS AGO WAS
FOUND DEAD.
AND RETURNED TO HIS OWNER AFTER
SPENDING MORE THAN A DECADE
LIVING AT DAVE'S TAXIDERMY SHOP.
WHATEVER.
>>> A MAN IN IRAN WENT TO THE
HOSPITAL AFTER HE GOT A BATTERY
STUCK INSIDE HIS PENIS.
IT WAS A DOUBLE AA BATTERY
BECAUSE THAT'S THE SOUND HE
MAKES WHEN IT GOES IN.
AH, AH!
>>> THIS YEAR MARKS THE 50th
ANNIVERSARY OF ONE OF MARVEL
COMICS FIRST BLACK SUPERHEROES,
LUKE CAGE.
IN THE COMICS, LUKE CAGE FACES
OFF AGAINST BLACK PEOPLE'S MOST
POWERFUL ENEMY OF THE 1970s,
LEAD PAINT.
>>> POLICE ARRESTED TWIN SISTERS
AFTER THEY GOT MAD AT A
RESTAURANT WORKER AND SHOT HIM
IN THE FACE.
THIS ACCORDING TO PEACOCK'S VERY
DARK REBOOT OF "SISTER, SISTER."
>>> THIS WEEK THE FDA GRANTED
THE FIRST CONDOM APPROVED FOR
ANAL SEX.
IT TOOK THEM THIS LONG BECAUSE
THEIR WIVES WOULD ONLY LET THEM
TEST IT ON THEIR BIRTHDAYS.
>> BUT DO YOU GET IT?
>> RESEARCHERS OBSERVED A
60-FOOT-TALL ROGUE WAVE, WHICH
IS THE LARGEST EVER RECORDED.
RESEARCHERS BELIEVE THE WAVE WAS
GENERATED WHEN YO MAMMA FELL
OVERBOARD.
For "Weekend Update," I'm
Colin Jost.
>> I'm Michael Che. Good night.